let's talk a little bit about
single-payer health care now that the
American Health Care Act is moving
through Congress we're even more so
concerned now that the state of health
care in the u.s. could get much worse
over the next few years and it's already
really really bad and a popular sort of
pushback to that is we should be looking
at single-payer health care we should
either take this as an opportunity to
push universal health insurance or
single-payer health care or state-level
single-payer health care or something so
let's go through this and talk it
through ok for anyone who doesn't know
first of all single-payer health care is
a system where everyone pays taxes into
a single fund that finances everybody's
health care as opposed to paying people
paying premiums to health insurance
companies and then the health insurance
companies decide what to cover at the
providers when you're talking about
single-payer you're talking about
circumventing the system of health
insurance altogether the government can
take all the money that is paid in and
either contract out to private service
providers that's how it's done in Canada
single-payer system or the government
can have their own medical facilities
and employees that's how it's done in
the United Kingdom there's really no one
way that this is done except for in the
United States we see a system that is
different then in just about every other
developed country every other developed
country in the world has a single-payer
type system of one kind or another ok we
actually were sort of going in this
direction in the United States in the
early 20th century wendell potter former
a Cigna executive writes about this in
his great book deadly spin and I've
interviewed him about it it ended up
being scrapped the US was going in the
direction of single-payer I think it was
between World Wars 1 and 2 and it was
scrapped partially because it was too
similar to what our enemy at the time
Germany was doing and instead we went in
the direction of this atrocious employer
connected for-profit health insurance
system nowhere in the u.s. is there a
single-payer system in place although
you do have government-run health care
when you look at programs like Medicare
and Medicaid all those a little bit
different
but there are possible state solutions
for single-payer health care which we
will talk about there's a couple of ways
that this could be done one is you could
provide health care to all residents of
a state even though the federal
government is going in the opposite
direction and and Vermont looked at
doing this although it's failed and
we'll talk about that a little bit later
this could be something which could also
if it started in one state maybe spread
to other states if it went well now it
would require raising state taxes in the
short run that's going to be a hit on
people's income most people Pat don't
cheer when their taxes are going to go
up even people who understand that taxes
are there for a reason it is very hard
to pass significant tax increases yeah
obviously people aren't going to cheer
for higher taxes at first but I think in
a few years once they realize how it
works they'll be more customed to the
idea and the fact that Social Security
and Medicare gets taken out of your
paychecks and their popular systems I
think really goes to that idea
California currently has a bill moving
through its legislature that would set
up a single-payer health care system in
the state the New York Health Act which
just passed the New York State Assembly
and is two votes short of being passed
in the Senate would enroll every New
Yorker in a state-run insurance program
as I mentioned Vermont actually passed a
bill in 2011 setting up a single-payer
system but the plan was abandoned in
2014 for a number of reasons which I'll
get into in a second a handful of other
states have introduced single-payer
legislation the bills have died
somewhere in the process before being
passed historically single-payer systems
save money they obviously give people
more coverage they tend to create better
health outcomes but the biggest stigma
surrounding single-payer is it increases
taxes and it needs government employees
if you're in the mindset Pat of a small
government smaller government agencies
lower taxes how on earth are you going
to be convinced of this I think you have
to make a moral argument that's the only
way I could imagine convincing a small
government conservative that this makes
sense and saying hey the morality of the
system we have
is essentially nil and we need to do
something more moral that's why I think
the state-by-state approach would be
very effective because that's how gay
marriage came to be the law of the land
yeah that's how it was with marijuana
you see more and more states adding on
to that I think that's a good approach
there's a there's a lot of there's a
strong case to be made so that when
Vermont walked away from its
single-payer system in 2014 it was still
in the process of being set up and
analyses showed that the system would
have nearly doubled the state budget if
fully implemented so a single-payer
system saves the government money in the
long term it does have significant
start-up costs and this is a challenge
for individual states Vermont would have
it would have needed to issue a two
hundred million dollar bond to fully
implement that system and states have to
abide by balanced budget laws it's much
harder for states to borrow money than
it is for the federal government so the
alternative solution was you drastically
raise taxes above the board and that's
very politically unpopular as well as
the reality that economies are cyclical
healthcare demand is pretty constant so
tax revenue fluctuates healthcare
spending would sort of stay the same and
in the beginning if you're just raising
this money it can still create funding
problems which Vermont had so I think
Pat that we really need a federal
single-payer system it's much more
financially viable but it's just such a
non-starter given the politicians we
currently have in place I don't think
that means that we shouldn't try though
because as we see at a federal level
some politicians are pushing for HR 676
we would expand Medicare for all the
many problem is obviously Republicans
are not going to get in support of this
but some Democrats won't either you have
people like Dianne Feinstein who say
that they're not ready to support
single-payer you have Hillary Clinton
who gave an applause line that
single-payer will never come to pass
that's why Medicare for all or the
expansion of Medicare is seen by many as
a good direction to go because you have
the system in place as I mentioned
earlier Medicare is a sort of
single-payer system you can say well
let's allow people to get into that
system a little bit earlier there's a
mechanism to just say hey you can buy in
to Medicare but then you
could subsidize the cost to buy into
Medicare at either the federal or state
level that's an approach that is
increasingly being discussed but I just
be when you've got a Republican house
and a Republican Senate and a Republican
president it's hard to imagine that
you're going to be able to do anything
federally and the problem is that
because of the patchwork of federal and
state laws who's allowed to do what and
when it's going to be tough to do it at
the state level it would definitely be
tough to do right now but I think
looking towards 2020 there could be a
resurgence of more progressive ideals
when it comes to health care because the
Affordable Care Act didn't go far enough
and now you have the Republican
replacement option which is polling it
anywhere from I think 17 to maybe thirty
eight percent yeah so there's going to
be a demand for an alternative to those
two systems and what's the most popular
system around the world its universal
health care it is and even within the
u.s. Medicare Medicare is not a perfect
system it has its problems but by and
large those who receive Medicare would
not want to lose it in favor of the
alternatives that are out there the
problem in the u.s. is mostly
ideological because as we've heard from
professors like Gerald Friedman from my
alma mater the University of
Massachusetts in Amherst it's completely
affordable when you eliminate so many of
the costs of the system we have and look
at a single-payer system
it's totally affordable people are
partisan and they're steeped in the
private industry is better dogma people
like this take a look at this video clip
with regard to the idea of whether or
not you have a right to a health care
you have to realize what that implies
it's not an abstraction I'm a physician
that means you have a right to come to
my house and can script to me means you
believe in slavery the games that you're
going to enslave not only me but the
janitor at my hospital right the person
who cleans my office the woman behind
Randy hall if you were watching that she
may be that's just the expression she
always has on her face but she seemed
genuinely perplexed by what Rand Paul
was saying and Bernie Sanders responded
to this by asking the healthcare
professional who was testifying to that
committee do you feel like a slave and
the whole room there laughed at him the
American healthcare act is and will
continue to be a disaster if it passes
the Affordable Care
act is a middle ground that hardly seems
ideal to anyone but you have people like
Rand Paul who were willing to go as far
as to say if health care is a right
doctors are slaves which is hard for me
to even really wrap my head around and
statistically here and abroad public
health care is more popular with
patients you hear these anecdotal
stories pat about Oh in Canada you've
gotta wait X number of months for Y
procedure there's no doubt that in any
system you are going to have individual
cases where someone waited longer than
what would be ideal but overall these
systems work pretty well there can be
delays for elective procedures there can
be delays for non urgent procedures but
by and large people like their systems
and in all of these countries that have
single-payer health care if you don't
like it you can supplement your care
with a private Platt plant and people
don't like this idea that we would be
rationing care but in this instance we
do rationing based off of the need that
the person has right whereas now we're
just rationing based off of how much
money you have we have rationing now
based on your ability to pay there's no
doubt about it and we hear story after
story after story pointing that out
you're completely right about that and
when you talk about remember death
panels Sarah Palin's death panels from
Obama care it's not true that Obama care
had death panels as described by Sarah
Palin but it's actually true that any
system that is based on merely ability
to pay is a form of death panel insofar
as people will die due to lack of access
to care and I don't know how much
further we have to go with the death
panel thing but bottom line the system
we have is immoral this isn't not
everything has to be to make a profit we
can still be a capitalist society that
says certain areas are not going to be
left merely to for-profit companies this
includes for example the building of
roads uncontroversially the military I
mean yes you've got these private
mercenary groups that do government
contracts but the military is a
socialist endeavor so to speak education
yes you can go to private schools but we
have public education
that are in some places and in others
healthcare healthcare need not be a
product to be bought and sold and the
government should be in charge of the
institution's where it doesn't make
sense to have a profit incentive for
them so as you mentioned the military
roads the police and I think healthcare
is first and foremost limitless even
with a socialist military we've still
figured out a way for contractors to
make nice little profits working with
the military but yet in principle the
military itself as Pat points out and as
I pointed out is on that list discuss
this with us on our reddit discussion
forum david pakman.com slash our EDD IT